in wall
triple duty represent represent both of
you before let me just
framework
we very joyously invited
Roosevelt here that is an effort that we
can I'm here or so go to bring back to
whittle economy academic scholarly
gestures which is very very important
part of Europe other crises they're
actually quite a number of people who
engage in questions of political economy
historical cultural perspective for all
sorts of reasons over the last couple
decades in which some of the practicing
here teaching here
we got together and this is particularly
so true thinking about Europe wide world
pray for also virgin studies on China
which had created great numbers of
questions about the nature of your
exception was impulsive manager about
signing exceptionalism so that what was
the background endeavor but I should add
that it was also terms of a kind of
academic politics that is we felt that
so much of the work Romeo recently
economics Business School apart by our
very own little prize winners in part by
extraordinary school development
qualities from Earth Institute doesn't
really do the kind of work that we feel
should be done doesn't engage a
historical perspective
Denver's especially thinking about what
is happening in the world so with that
larger agenda you'll be able to
contribute to the first present briefly
we'll see how so welcome so we hope to
get Charles mayor and mobile colleagues
speaking about just very best economy
girls around 0 now we are getting
adrenaline how for the school of
questions and they raised around
divergence of convergence very very
eminent will afford to have welcomed
your would call that Bob who has come
back who work on social history
institution
yeah we've already thought of however
feels now has got it filled with a
bigger world is too much you know focus
he's gone back to the books it will come
to us only and thanks fault we will work
throughout Carl better lid and other
colleagues work on perfect ilysm and we
hope to bring it Peter Hall has worked
out for all his capitalism I called the
Harvard School I'm sure they call of
that and in the process we hope will not
call me in school and I would be some
elements of that we start let me start
by introducing coming to us for UCLA
where he is directed many research
programs and new initiatives around a
the Asian Studies feel as anything goes
over research is examine Chinese
patterns political
change especially since the 18th century
his first work by understanding was on
the political economy of food supplies
in Jake China and then his very
important book was published 9907 on
China transform is grow up of change in
the limits of human experience a work
that the European isn't simply not
engaged enough but Patrick work full
intellectually ambitious at wholly
original and a real challenge the social
sciences and again it's interesting that
until this boy recent work in some ways
a European this had not officially gauge
concerning not us but I also do a
sufficiently in Europe least not
apartment contemporary
is is he's interested which he's
developed a beast earlier work it's a
subjective threescore least of articles
which are proposed many languages and
journals in the Academy but also in
other voices outside of the Academy so
they have very significant
development
generally after cogent it's outside
remarkably friendly critiques of his
colleague Ken appearances going to great
divergence 2002 junk with Jordan frozen
all content to right before young
divergence politics of economic change
china europe which came out
party of two thousand
afterwards colleagues Richard bullet how
at zealot you
thank you for inviting me and Jean LaRon
Rosenthal here it's a great
disappointment I'm sure to many in the
room perhaps was especially me that he's
not here to share in the excitement of
speaking before gathering which I hope
has people both from the European
studies part of the campus as well as
from the East Asian part I notice both
Institute's are represented I also
noticed that the Weatherhead has a
banner roughly half the width of the
European but also spatially placed in
front and I still don't quite understand
that the symbolic significant in which I
should read that the spatial placement
but I'm conscious that they're both
behind me and I'm speaking to you though
in fact I find it very hard I can't I
have to choose I mean unless I want to
get a strained neck I really can't keep
track of all of you in terms of as I
look out so any but I won't even really
try I do want to say that if genre that
this talk is a talk by genre and myself
we have presented the book in different
venues individually and together we
really consciously conceived this as an
ABA be presentation this beginning would
have been by him he's at least he's
probably not quite a foot 9 inches
taller than I am much deeper voice and
as a European esteem the remarks you
would open with he would have given with
more gusto than I feel confident in
doing but I'm going to still open with
the remarks that he and i set up
together and then moved through the talk
and one of the disadvantages not having
him here is that the discipline of going
a Bab and knowing we only have 25 to 30
minutes he gets very impatient and so I
would have been careful not to stray but
there's so many tempting things to talk
about in the context of the introduction
thinking about Europe it's similar the
importance of the political economy the
EU part of this book where it ends up
which I'm not going to talk about much
today is an argument that finally Europe
in the early 21st century is confronting
some of the kinds of problems of scale
that Chinese regime's have been
repeatedly confronting for centuries and
so that some of the issues that we think
of as being super estate our super state
and European world region within a
Chinese context they've been what's been
within a single polity for a long time
and the issue of the size of our units
the way they work there are a lot of
fruitful the issues that we can come
that we come to us when we don't
naturalise one set of experiences is the
norms according to which we judge the
others but that's actually not what I'm
going to specifically talk about i'm
going to introduce this book give you an
overview of the book i'm going to then
talk about how it is different from what
Ken Pomeroy's does in the great
divergence it's related to but a
different approach then I'm going to
exemplify some of the arguments in the
book by walking through one chapter in
particular and then finally I'm going to
suggest the kind of agenda for research
that we think is worth pursuing and that
we consciously wrote the book thinking
about how we could make statements that
would help sort of proposed a way to
think about how social science history
at least one of the ways it can be more
effectively pursued and so you can see
the teapots that was the symbolism here
initially Harvard gave us a Japanese
iron teapot which I thought
aesthetically was much more lovely but
regrettably inappropriate and I could
not find a persuasive way to displace
that ugly a pot on the right and I guess
I guess not to sort of get essential as
they put genre under this Chinese pot
and me under that other kind of pot
anybody
there we have it so part one motivation
and outline in thinking about coming
here and talking to an audience that
were sponsored first and foremost by the
European Institute here thinking about
in the history of ideas China and Asia
more generally holds a special place for
Europeans thinking from the
Enlightenment forward about politics
themes of their being either a wise
Emperor or an evil emperor and those
themes were complimented in the 18th
century by the classical economists
specifically Smith and Malthus and in
the images they gave us in related ways
of systems of economy in which
populations grow and at which with Smith
according to the institution's reach a
certain kind of equilibrium scale of a
height of growth and this leads in the
Malthusian version of this to the notion
of course of populations growing to a
point where they're at their in a
subsistence kind of equilibrium and the
danger of overpopulation it seems that
these kind of framings are related also
to how we do economic history
professionally in the early 21st century
where we are still very much animated in
part at least by the desire of at least
some of the people in this field
implicitly or x explicitly to take pride
or at least credit in being the cradle
of modern economic growth and
increasingly it seems to me one could
understand this is a kind of nostalgia
but I'm not going to go into that kind
of issue my wife works in London so I'm
acutely aware of the actual state of the
British economy and its infrastructure
in London etc cetera but I as I say I'm
not gonna I'll be dissipating John Ross
staring at me and getting ready to
grumble if I go off on something like
that so instead i'll talk about that
within this context economic historians
have who don't work on China but who
aspire to make broader statements have
frequently invoked the political system
of China as in imperial times as a
source for the failure of China
to become more prosperous at the same
time we do from the in the earlier part
of the Enlightenment in the 18th century
have this vision of China's peaceful and
prosperous so what I'm stressing is that
within the history of ideas China has
appeared in both positive and negative
lights that's true in the 18th century
and it's in fact true today and these
have a lot to do in the 18th century
with political debates in Europe much
more than what they said about what was
going on in China and that even today if
we go through and we think about our
current context of a global economy in
which we really have anxieties about
differences in rates of growth the
impact of changes in China on our
economic situation there is a consistent
desire to both praise and blame China
today in California in the newspapers in
the last couple of weeks their articles
that praise China in reference to the
California's desperate need to develop
some kind of public transportation
involving high-speed trains and the same
newspapers there are all kinds of
stories in the business pages about
problems of trade desires to restrict
what the Chinese are doing penalize them
for this that or the other a lot of
these discussions in the strongest form
of presentations we could say tell us
really little about how China works
itself but much more about what makes us
anxious either things we don't have or
things we're worried about losing and
for that matter Chinese do very similar
exercises there in terms of using the US
as a mirror to view both their
advantages and disadvantages or
strengths and weaknesses as defined by
different political groups so this
exercise is not a peculiar American
exercise or European one it's one people
seem to do with some regularity around
the world but the key is it doesn't
really produce new knowledge Jean Lall
wrote this slide so it says scientific I
try to avoid that that claim but he's a
he's a hardcore economist so he believes
in that and I actually I believe in some
of that too I should be I got to be
careful here
there is a party line and I am part of
the party but so Jean Ron I decided
there is a whole lot of research on
China in Europe but it's hard to excess
and evaluate on one's own if one's an
outsider to a literature that it really
is important to bring the research
together in a certain way so I'm going
to review some somewhat of how we came
into this book and stress that we do not
aim at a new synthesis we're not aiming
anything grand but we do claim to be
offering at least what we think is a
framework for thinking about issues and
addressing them at seriatim recognizing
the issues addressed in a more
analytically focused in empirical manner
can over time build up a more solid base
of knowledge so the book has the
following chapters we talked about space
and politics this has to do with the
difference between empire and and from
an imperial perspective fragment at
political space I'll say more about that
later we have a chapter on demography
and the way demography is used with
relation to economic growth both in
Malthus the classical economists and
more recently chapter three on formal
and informal mechanisms has to do with
the nature of trade and I'm going to go
through that chapter some of its key
arguments with you in a moment chapter
four which is many ways our explanation
of why there was a divergence I will
speak about briefly later as well the
last two substantive chapters are about
first credit markets meaning private
finance and then about public finance
chapters five and six and then we end
with a broader theme attic sweep of how
to think about growth and the political
economy to grow between 1500 and in the
beginning the post-world war two
beginning of the post-world War two ERA
okay so breaking away from the great
divergence debate we started this
project many years ago thinking about it
and in periodically thinking we should
write something we ended up writing two
or three papers together and decided
that we should really get serious sent
and plot out six chapters or so and
create a book and then over the last I
guess between five and three years ago
that's what we did so there's really
four elements that we thought quite
consciously about one is the economics
and history as disciplines each has at
least in some of their subfields
conceptual coherence and and the demands
of what we're studying means we have to
be analytically coherent and from
history especially we have to be
empirically plausible economists love to
use stylized facts which simplify and
there's really a point to
simplifications but when the
simplifications reached the point of
simply being untenable having untenable
relations to reality the historians in
each of us rebels and says that's not a
set of principles worth pursuing so
empirical plausibility and conceptual
coherence the effort to sustain both
through the use of comparable
information that's symmetric meaning we
have comparable that we're comparing is
it worth like and like rather than an
example of not doing that would be
looking at pawnshop interest rates in
China versus public bond rates in Europe
there are two very different kinds of
finance there's no reason we should
expect interest rates in one kind of
situation to resemble those in another
so we need comparable kinds of
information about finance to to be able
to make useful statements so over
several years that we discussed this
book we made each other read a lot about
the other regions history and we
reflected quite carefully about what
each discipline was demanding in terms
of the types of questions it framed the
methods that used the types of data
found congenial and we tried to
adjudicate amongst those how to come up
with what we thought was a synthetic
narrative and if and we were very
conscious that we couldn't really
address any topic where we thought we
were lacking in one of the four elements
if we thought we couldn't be
conceptually coherent about how
something worked if we didn't have
enough empirical information and if that
China and Europe information weren't at
least somewhat symmetric there's much
more written about Europe so there's a
constant tension in effort to make China
live up to the sort of the empirical
density of material in Europe and even
if it can't always do so the being
mindful of the challenge and the problem
strikes us is very important so the
rules of the game are we resist
inductive temptation everyone who does
comparison or many people tend to think
have their favorite differences but have
no particular way of evaluating when
differences that exist matter or don't
matter part of what we do in the book is
trying to suggest differences and I'll
give you an example in a moment
differences can exist but how do they
matter that turns out to be a quite
challenging issue the mere plausibility
of differences mattering is inadequate
for making claims that something is
important to make claims about what is
important in terms of differences we
have to move down a level to look at
specific problems ones that Chinese
Europeans both face in terms of economic
activities and which they solve in one
way or another so that we can actually
evaluate what they see what they do and
what the consequences of those efforts
might be so what are the implications of
this for thinking about the great
divergence as I'm sure many of you are
familiar with ken ken pomeroy's is
important work of two thousand the great
divergence that book argues and it's
certainly a claim that more generally
also exists in part in China transformed
a book victoria mentioned that i
published as earlier and that many other
scholars many of whom were in the state
of california mentally if not physically
I started arguing in the 1990s and early
2000s so that there were important
similarities that that matter to to
getting a baseline for how things
changed after the late 18th century in
Ken's case he strutted Palmer axes case
he stressed in particular European
expansion is a new world and the
importance of resources in the new world
the windfall gain that this created and
he tied it in particular to the the
cotton textile experience and he also
hung a lot on the fortuitous location of
coal in Britain compared to its location
in the Chinese mainland so the the great
strengths of this book it seems to me or
one of its great strengths is the way it
has really engaged a broad range of
scholars and students amongst economists
there's been a great effort to get
create new research on wages and prices
on costs of living I think most
economists believe now they've beaten
back the Pomerantz thesis about the
comparability of standards of living you
know the jury may still be out but there
many people betting on the jury coming
back with a verdict that no the
Europeans were ahead of China well
before Pomerance claims they were
Rosenthal and Wong think that this is
sort of a in a relevant exercise that is
it doesn't matter what the precise
quantitative difference is what we
really should be interested in is the
mechanisms that were work in both parts
of the world and explain why one set of
mechanisms was more likely to create
modern economic growth than the other at
the same time as economists turned to
doing new research historians were swept
up with thinking about connections the
way it framed and fit into interest in
global history and in general it really
helped bring chinese history into more
general discussions of European and
world history you know
in a very productive manner that has
persisted for the last decade all right
there are critiques of course a lot of
people have said now the new world
resources are not been important for a
variety of reasons and the location of
coal is is overstated in the book
there's a general I would like to state
it however in terms of the general
problem of explaining individual
historical cases that in many ways are
distinct narratives so that if you have
a large scale and complex process
sorting out the significance of
individual factors becomes extremely
difficult and essentially if we define
the Industrial Revolution to be that set
of things that happened in England and
we label everything that happened there
in the end what we're describing is what
happened in England we don't have it's
very hard to know where the general
story is in that in the narrative so
before and Beyond divergence the book
Rosenthal and I wrote really tried to be
quite careful about thinking what does
it mean to develop a more general model
of explaining what are the key factors
that lead to modern economic growth as
they appear empirically the plausibility
of them appearing empirically in China
and Europe so we have we wanted to obey
or obey believe in and choose a verb but
we use economic principles very
straightforward economic principles and
we anchor it in major our reading of
large amounts of historical evidence so
what we do and do not try to do we're
not trying to explain the British
industrial revolution that's in some
ultimate sense a one-off event that has
its own a cluster of specificities but
so rather than get bogged down and
what's historically particular to the
British narrative but may not be
actually crucial to economic growth in a
more general set of possibilities we're
trying to come up with a with causal
mechanisms we think would have been
crucial whether or not for instance you
had new world cotton
we tend to think that new world cotton
was not essential it certainly made a
difference but it's a second-order kind
of difference because unless there were
a lot of other kinds of changes new
world cotton would never mattered and
even if you needed new world cotton did
you have to get it the way Europeans got
it in other words that you have to have
the import of African slaves etc etc
this is a large set of counterfactuals
but what we're trying to do is tease out
the degree to which one can imagine a
number of different situations in which
some basic differences between China and
Europe would still lead to divergence in
ken's in kenpom rinses terms so our
thesis is that politics is very
important because there's a key and
persistent difference between China and
Europe indeed it's one that other
scholars have noted before but we think
have in the bluntest form fundamentally
misread the key is not some notion of
autocracy versus democracy but it's
really spatial scale and in particular
the costs of war which we think very
with spatial scale so to put it in
simplest terms in chapter 4 we argue
that the persistent possibilities of
warfare in early modern Europe led to an
urban bias in the location of certain
types of European manufacturing that we
have an assumption that urban sites for
manufacturing are better but empirically
in the sixteenth and seventeenth
centuries wages were higher in in the
city life expectancy was lower you had
to the cost of food was higher in the
cities it was cheaper in fact then to
manufacture crafts in the countryside
and in China after the late 14th century
increasingly we see crafts in the
countryside and in Europe in the late
seventeenth and in the 18th century we
also see in that so-called proto
industry ulm oment in certain locations
both in england the zurich highlands and
other parts of german-speaking areas as
well as a few French areas we see
manufacturing taking place in the
countryside as well but we think by that
point in time there's still an urban
has to persist in Europe that leads that
that has an impact on subsequent
development that the urban location of
and bias of European manufacturing which
was in LA in key ways motivated by the
fear of warfare ends up later on with
the unintended consequence of being more
advantageous for the development of the
economy because in cities capital is
cheaper relative to labor that is to say
well capital is cheaper in cities than
it is in a countryside it's cheaper to
borrow this has derivative of issues of
surveillance that getting repaid but
labour is more expensive so a difference
in relative factor costs means that if
your if your industries and cities
you're more likely to develop
technologies that are going to use
capital rather than use labour and that
kind of sort of economic demand driven
factor seems to us at least enough to
tilt things in a direction that at some
point you would expect a difference to
emerge in the way these two economies
broadly speaking developed the use of
capital and labor now in saying this we
also want to stress this is the contrast
that emerges to us by looking at Europe
and China as examples of one place that
had fragmented polities and another that
had a large empire it's not saying that
all large political spaces are
necessarily like China nor is it saying
that all places that have intense
political competition and military
warfare are like Europe you can have
political competition and not have the
other conditions that clearly also
inform the ways the European political
system developed so it's in making
comparisons between two parts of the
world that are different it's important
to recognize this level of claim we
consciously avoid saying that China's
like all of the Empire's because we
don't believe that normally believe all
places with small and competing polities
have the same kind of political system
and therefore the contrast between China
and Europe is between one particular and
important world region with a set of
competing polities and one important
world region where the place was
organized as
as Empire now the beyond divergence in
our presentation is to say we had that
comparative economic history clearly
includes some effort to explain why
things diverge at a certain point in
time or deciding when that is and what
it was but it includes many other things
and our book tries to explain how
different societies tackle similar
problems and note that even if the
solution those problems don't directly
and immediately affect the likelihoods
of industrialization they actually
remain relevant well after
industrialization processes begin and
spread and so one of our arguments is
understanding dynamics before
industrialization helps explain the
nature of economic growth in different
world regions even a century or two
later so let me move quickly to chapter
three and part three of this
presentation and talk about markets and
institutions so in chapter three what we
do is we walk through up analysis of
formal and informal institutions there
is a kind of traditional narrative that
says which has been revised by many
scholars including people in this room
but in you know 20 years ago many people
would argue China was an era an area
that was characterized by informal
mechanisms you had extensive family and
lineage groups native place groups the
absence of formal kinds of institutions
like Europeans formal laws contract law
local courts and constitutions and what
this kind of contrast meant especially
in development in the field of
development economics is the logic that
those places with bad informal
institutions were locked into being poor
that's the theme that's been in certain
strands in the development economic
literature for the
at least 10 15 years and applied to
history it would say you can explain why
China's poor because it it had an
oppressive Emperor it had this reliance
on family groups etc etc but we've had
important and crucial revisions in last
more than a decade really after greif
has really made clean elegant economic
models of why informal institutions
existed amongst different groups in
Europe and they worked Matty's Ellen and
others who work with her have
demonstrated the crucial importance of
formal contracts and many other aspects
of business organization which make sort
of the caricature difference between
chinese and european forms far less
dramatic than they had once seemed and
once we recognize that both China and
Europe had mixes of formal and informal
institutions which i think is what
avner's Abner graves work Mattie's Ellen
elder scholars who have been associated
with both of them and the types of work
they do what they collectively are
telling us in light of the earlier
knowledge we had is both China and
Europe had formal and informal
institutions so Rosenthal and I said all
right if that's true how can we locate
differences between these places are the
differences in terms of market
institutions between large places like
China and Europe or they differences or
variations within each of those areas
more than between them now there was one
of the basic things about making
comparisons is what are your units of
analysis when you recognize that the
unit is in homogeneous can you
distinguish when you're explaining
variations within a unit from those
variations between units clearly there's
variations in the Chinese economy the
variations in the European economy we
have to be sure that those variations we
see within either these world regions we
can distinguish analytically from the
key differences we want to pose between
the two world regions so for instance of
market institutions one of the first
things we noticed one of the things that
challenges us to think about this
analytically
is that Europe has fragmented political
boundaries so the the difficulty of
thinking about economic problems within
political units becomes a challenge what
is international trade in Europe is
simply trade within the Empire in China
but what we observe and what people have
known for a long time is that in early
modern Europe trade across Europe was
largely informal that is to say there
was a inability to enforce contracts
formally at long distance China had this
was not international trade in China but
it was also long-distance trade and we
discovered long distance trade it was
also informal there was the the relative
importance of formal contract and as the
source of formal adjudication was also
fairly small so we this observation then
led us to say all right so how do we
model this how do you actually sort of
explain what we're likely to find
historically is there a parsimonious way
to explain this so we ended up designing
that we would just think about two
factors the frequency of transactions
and the distance between the two parties
transacting so the the graph on the left
has the the value of the payment on the
vertical axis and has the distance
between the borrower and lender this is
a credit issue the way we'd this is a
slide that shows credit on the
horizontal axis so the blue line that
stays fixed is the value of the loan and
the red line that rises is the cost of
enforcing that contra the loan agreement
that's and the and the intuition of this
is the further apart the borrower and
lender the higher the cost of enforcing
the loan and beyond a certain in a court
formally and so beyond a certain
distance you're not going to rely on
formal institutions like courts you're
going to have to enforce these
agreements in some other way so that's
the issue of
on the right side is issue of frequency
of transactions or the time between
transactions here the again the the
horizontal blue line is the value that
someone receives if he cheats right now
and gets away with it and the red line
is essentially you you get you get 10
units of value from each transaction but
what happens then is the frequency of
transactions changes so that the more
transactions you have that it's the
closer you are to the origin the more
value you get and it's actually worth it
to you not to cheat but the less
frequent your transactions then in fact
cheating is a it turns out to be a good
idea and and the issue is how does
reputation keep you from cheating and
you're going to have to choose one of
these mechanisms as basically being more
effective than the other that's so the
intuition is that that whether you
choose formal or informal mechanisms is
a function of distance and time so let
me I'll fill this in more imperior give
you examples of this first a simple two
by two table we say that if the distance
is closer than a certain distance it's
easier to enforce contracts through
courts and you're especially likely to
do that if the frequency with which you
do these things is infrequent so that
it's worth it for you to invest in
having a court system that enforces
something if you don't do it that often
and it's at a close enough distance that
the two parties can be brought together
that's the logic of why you use formal
the farther you go away the upper right
hand corner forma becomes less feasible
but if the time is also not very
frequent you probably can't enforce
things informally either and so we
predict you only see cash being
in that case in the lower right-hand
corner where you're still at a great
distance but the frequency of
transactions is frequent then sound form
of reputation is likely to be able that
is informal mechanisms are likely to
work to make tray possible and in the
the cell in the lower left it turns out
you can have conceivably either formal
or informal mechanisms now there are
empirical things that we can associate
with each of these and what's
significant is the degree to which
they're both that the contrast obtained
in both China and Europe that is the
rest we can see distance and time
operating in similar ways whether you're
in China or in Europe or whether you're
working between them so that upper right
part of the box where we see neither
formal no informal the example is
initially when Europeans go to China and
they buy Chinese goods and they bring
silver to pay for them they have to
bring all the silver Chinese don't offer
any credit there's no there's no credit
dimension to the transaction because
there's no trust in future transact in
the transactions are not frequent enough
to create the informal mechanisms expand
those distances if we look at where we
find formal institutions we find that
for land whether you're in China and
Europe there will be contracts so when
the Chinese case even though a
transaction could be between kin or
people who are in the same native place
they're still going to be there's likely
going to be a contract so it's not that
informal Trump's formal in all cases you
still have contracts for land in China
as
do in Europe or at least something
similar on the other hand where there's
no formal but you have informal that was
the lower right of that two by two that
is long distance trade in long-distance
trade whether you're in Europe or in
China both family and reputation matter
to both and then in that cell where you
could have either formal or informal you
find both and that's true in both parts
of the world so the first thing we
establish is the stylized contrast
between Europeans have any formal
institutions in China is having informal
is exaggerated there's a baseline of
similarity that can be explained by
factors of distance in time frequency of
transactions and distance of the parties
connected by transactions but that said
we then want to go to a second-level
nails and say but there are there's a
significance to political scale the size
of the of the political unit will
influence the relative importance of
these two mechanisms so what we do o is
we have a blank slide well I'm going to
say that's when he wrote oh there it is
yeah that's the rest of it I see so
here's the rest of the slide so what we
what essentially this 3 by 3 does is it
develops the intuition and lays out that
if in fact the Chinese because they had
a large imperial space develop more
long-distance trade earlier than
Europeans which broadly speaking seems
to make sense according to the
qualitative evidence that exists then
what this means is that they developed
informal mechanisms more fully in an
earlier stage than Europeans did and
therefore the capacity of informal
mechanisms to work well we'll cover more
cases than it will in Europe conversely
because Europeans develop formal
institutions that is courts and
contracts in larger numbers earlier on
that is to deal with kinds of
transactions closer at hand they were
because they had developed these they
could extend them
more easily so the extension of the
kinds of institutions you initially
develop covers space coming from either
direction Chinese are more likely to use
certain kinds of informal institutions
in areas where either could be used and
Europeans are more likely to use formal
that's essentially what these
inequalities express in sort of a
notional form so what we're trying to do
is give it an explanation for how China
and Europe in very important ways in
terms of market institutions cannabase
similar basic principles but the
relative importance of how those
institutions develop is influenced by
political scale and the way political
scale influences the way trade develops
that at least is the is the nature of
our argument now the implications of
this as I say if long-distance trade
develops earlier in China and develops
to a greater degree the use of informal
institutions is going to have more
potential for extension that it does in
in Europe and the converse the converse
in Europe in terms of formal
institutions and what this means then as
a corollary is that the the
unwillingness to provide formal
institutions in China is not a sign that
informal will always prevail in China it
could simply be that it's an affirmation
of the effectiveness of the of the
institutions that are being used and
what we do see in China certainly in
late 19th or 20th century is increasing
shifts to formal institutions or rather
informal institutions in some ways
becoming more formal that's one of the
things that happens we change over time
so the key is these economies change and
the role of different institutions does
evolve there isn't the kind of lock in
some development economist imagine that
if you have informal institutions you
never get rid of them unless you just
sort of blow them up and import formal
institutions from abroad but rather
economies historically are able to have
their institutions change over time
and that it in both China and Europe we
can see the relevance of both formal and
informal institutions so the takeaway
that matters for thinking about economic
history is institutional at any moment
time what exists in terms of the
institution's their formal institutions
informal institutions affects what's
going to happen subsequently but it
doesn't lock it in it's not as if
institutions don't change and in some
sense within economics at least a
certain theme with path dependence it
seems to us for this kind of purpose has
been oversold all right so where does
this lead us I want to conclude by
suggesting some of the ways that we have
we're proposing an agenda in our book we
you know this is our was not a book
intended to start a debate and it's
certainly not a book that intends to end
a debate but rather we're trying to
exemplify ways to develop research and
the conversation amongst people working
on different parts of the world in a
common research effort so let me relate
some of the things that happen in the
book to two sets of issues one has to do
with culture and ideas because Rosenthal
and I were very careful we have we
actually take ideas quite seriously but
not in the way that at least historians
in the last 15 20 years think of ideas
and thus we're very careful not to
invoke culture in some abstract way in
comparisons between China and Europe
issues of culture or the term culture
has been invoked in multiple ways and we
think typically in ways that are
difficult to evaluate culture is used by
some historians the way some people
usually not economists invoke the market
in some abstract sense culture and
market are equally unusable as concepts
to explain anything because they're
simply too general so I want to say a
few things about how we do think about
ideas or how we use them in this book
and then I want to draw
some linkages between past and present
that seek to demonstrate why we think
it's important to observe practices in
earlier periods even if they didn't
themselves lead to industrialization
they can affect the way in which modern
economic growth takes place at a later
time so culture and how we bring it back
in and in the census we do it carefully
or we hope we do we avoid what are
typically considered cultural
explanations because those are non
falsifiable anytime you say Europeans
believed x and therefore they did why
then you say well you know Chinese
didn't believe X and so they didn't have
why well there's no real way there's no
data you can assemble that would ever
say that's wrong I mean because you the
game is over by just saying Europeans
have it Chinese don't therefore there's
a net me I mean in a sense is that true
or not true there's no real way to tell
see I mean in a strict sort of sense and
so the truth value of that's hard to
establish that's what it's not
falsifiable that doesn't seem a good way
to build knowledge so as you can
Roosevelt along with definitely people
who believe you can build knowledge and
so we're not so we don't fall into the
crowd that I remember once Marshall
Sahlins and a talk when someone
criticize something he was saying that
he did not suffer from so much
epistemological hypochondria that he
didn't think there was a world out there
and so we think there's a world out
there and we think we can do something
to understand it so but with cultural
explanations it's very difficult if not
impossible to specify the causal
mechanisms and typically we run a bunch
of traits together and we don't know
which ones are necessary which are
incidental whether it's the conjunction
of them of their few key ones it's very
hard to parse and indeed in those
instances famous instances where
cultural values have been invoked to
have causal consequences it seems people
don't often recall that when the class
of cases
namely max Faber the whole point of the
Protestant ethic was the degree to which
there were unintended consequences of
religious beliefs for economic behavior
it was not they weren't Protestant in
order to grow their economies and and
that's and yet and no one actually
literally says it that way but if if you
think about the ways in which we think
about cultural variables often there's
an intentionality associated with some
of them that is anxiety-provoking in
terms of making explanations at the same
time though we do argue that ideas
matter and we try to suggest how
certainly we believe that the ideas of
Chinese public economy fit a large
polity they make sense in terms of how
and why that state promotes material
security and that those ideas inform the
way institutions develop and the way
institutions develop purposes aren't or
rather people using institutions have
purposes so in economic terms it means
if you're going to look at the economic
consequences of ideas and beliefs we
have to recognize that those ideas and
beliefs are mediated by and made
implementable through institutions those
are what inform and promote certain
kinds of behaviors and discourage others
and I should say by institutions I'm
using the term is being used the way
economist use institutions that is to
say as opposed to sociologists
institutions are a set of rules and
norms that govern behavior that's what
institutions are so ideas and beliefs on
economic matters change within a culture
it's not the culture that matters it's
the kind of ideas and beliefs that exist
within a culture that can be drawn upon
and which can be open to new ideas from
without as well as elaboration and
transformation of ideas within and it's
how those ideas work upon institutions
that ultimately affect both the choices
people make as well as the kind of
outcomes I'm sorry you guys
back the whole time and you probably
can't can you even see this oh you do
okay sorry about that um so some of the
ideas institution is a political economy
that emerged in China we try to show are
actually similar to what we find in your
room and others are quite different and
it's the effort to sort through both and
evaluate when differences do and don't
matter and to acknowledge similarities
often are significant that the book is
dedicated to soaring through finally
then the final point has to do with as
we're explaining economic change
historically our basic argument is we
want to see if we can explain where
there's economic success by explaining
how institutions of different sorts
enable what levels and kinds of success
and that we should be able to use
general kinds of principles locate their
operation in particular context and
therefore explain with the use of theory
what's going on historic now if we end
up as I alluded to before thinking the
economic success the Industrial
Revolution for instance and essentially
if you look at all the things written in
this revolution some scholar has said
everything that existed in your if you
add it all up everything that existed in
England in 1752 1780 was important and
for each of those individual scholars
whatever they wrote about was important
but how we adjudicate the relevance of
the all those many different individual
importances is a difficult in B doesn't
give us the basis upon which to generate
general explanations of economic change
of any particular kind or more general I
don't mean universal but I mean more
general than being that is to say beyond
great britain so and the exercise that
comparative economic history often
engages in that is the inference that I
can show you reasons why Great Britain
was more successful therefore means I
can show you why other places were less
successful that whole logic is a problem
matic set of assumptions behind it that
are hard to substantiate in our book
tries to demonstrate where that kind of
reasoning leads people astray so in the
end then in terms of long-term history
what this beyond divergence issue we
raise long-term history really matters
Jean Lauren was born and raised in
Provence but he he went to read colleges
in undergrad so he he both came to the
US but a very strange place in the u.s.
he also actually this I don't know how
why this matters but in a sense it does
he did an undergraduate degree in
history I did mine in economics he grew
up and decided to be an economist I got
older and decided i want to be in
historian so we we reversed in graduate
school but i guess in a sense he remains
a very committed close reader of history
and a commitment to long day of a kind
of history is something we we tend to
share as a as a principal i guess and
even what we do in this book is is
claimed that political scale matters and
it for economic change in particular in
the pre industrial area it mattered
specifically for the likelihood of
developing long-distance commerce if you
have an imperial space a pacific space
in which that government is providing
peace and security in broad measure then
you should expect commerce if all the
other things being equal it will develop
more easily and we further more than
argue that the consequences of the
changes what made for europe's
development of Industry and
capital-intensive technology uses much
of that change was unanticipated prior
to 1800 no European was planning
industrialization I mean that just
wasn't in the in the game and yet if you
look back at how economics torian's talk
about the early modern period you would
think these states were deliberately
promoting
policies that were intended to create
industrialization and this is a kind of
anachronistic argument in most cases but
once the Industrial Revolution happens
by the 1820s certainly by 1850 the issue
of how other world regions will either
imitate or reject what is either English
or increasingly more European generally
that is a fundamentally different set of
circumstances have existed up through
the late 18th century and so that as we
recognize the game changer that the
Industrial Revolution is and I've now
recalled it jolinar must have written
this slide because I would never say
game changer but any event I'm saying it
now it's a game changer and what this
means is that when other other places
have the opportunity to industrialize
the way they will do so will continue to
be influenced by practices that predate
industrialization and I think the last
slide will explain this and I'm going to
insert parenthetically that unlike the
book we wrote the book really is was
written by doing heavy outlining before
one of us started writing then the other
one took anything was written and
rewrote it and was rewritten enough
times that it's it's actually not clear
at least to me typically who's
responsible for which paragraphs in
preparing this talk i have to admit we
each took blocks and wrote different
parts so i'm still being reminded by
different choices of words that we have
so the implications for analyzing more
recent changes we argue that changes in
institutional practices can come not
merely from adopting foreign ones but by
elaborating and changing domestic ones
so when we look for instance in recent
chinese history to the 1980s and the
explosion of what they're called
township and village enterprises which
were these small-scale industries
outside the planned economy man outside
of large cities what we see in our
opinion
is the reliance on various kinds of
informal mechanisms and institutions to
expand market exchange and organize
production that are in no sense the same
as existed before but they are drawing
upon the institutional preferences that
people at least had quite distinct from
what the state imposed so that what we
want to suggest more generally is the
particular institutional mixes that
account for how industrialization takes
place in different parts of the world
the institutional mixes what's formal
what's informal the nature of informal
these will vary there's no single
optimal mix of institutions
institutional evolution is context
specific and the notion of there being
principles according to which we can
evaluate institutions but not imagining
that there's a universal optimal type of
mix it seems to us is an important
observation argument or suggestion I'll
tomosynthesis ikan on the history of the
more recent times is to recognize that
historical factors matter is much a
systemic systemic meaning the the
context of relations that a given place
has with other places be these economic
or political and that there are spatial
variations as well as common elements
that characterize different situations
and our challenges really to
simultaneously identify both what's
varied amongst different situations and
what connects them in terms of necessary
principles or common phenomena because
of systemic connections I could talk
about the EU and things like that which
I'm tempted to do but I know I'm running
I've run out of time so I will exercise
self-restraint before I'm restrained
and stop there so thank you